toujours difficile à recevoir
et les traitements parfois
éprouvants. Dans le cas
de la radiothérapie,
une nouvelle approche pourrait
faire en sorte qu'une seule dose
soit suffisante pour traiter
certains cancers du sein.
♪ ♪ ♪
- (journaliste): Le cancer.
Il nous propulse, malgré nous,
sur la voie d'un long parcours.
D'abord consacrés
aux traitements, les premiers
pas sont éprouvants.
- Normalement, quand
il y a un traitement complet,
avec la chimio,
puis la radiothérapie,
la patiente, malheureusement,
doit s'absenter pendant un an,
au total. C'est ce qu'on lui
donne comme arrêt de travail,
ce qui est énorme.
- Une fois sur deux, l'espoir
d'une guérison passe par des
traitements de radiothérapie.
- Il peut y avoir 15, 20,
30 séances de radiothérapie.
Puis tout ce parcours-là pouvait
facilement prendre un an, là.
- Et si on pouvait réduire
le nombre de traitements?
Eh bien, c'est ce que permet
maintenant la radiothérapie
portative.
Autrefois, on amenait
le patient en radiothérapie.
Aujourd'hui, c'est l'inverse.
- Les appareils
de radiothérapie, c'est
des gros appareils. En général,
ils sont coulés dans le béton
du plancher. Mais on pouvait pas
le déplacer pour s'ajuster
au patient. Là, on a un appareil
qui est quand même assez pesant,
mais qu'on peut déplacer dans
les ascenseurs de l'hôpital,
à la limite, qu'on pourrait
déplacer entre deux blocs
opératoires.
- Devenu portatif, l'appareil
permet une chose incroyable :
faire de la radiothérapie
durant la chirurgie.
- La patiente qui est éligible
arrive de l'extérieur,
puis en un traitement,
entre guillemets, c'est
un "one stop pit shop". Et tout
son traitement, à part la chimio
si nécessaire, est déjà terminé.
C'est un gros avantage
aux patientes qui pourraient
retourner au travail
quatre semaines après.
- Montréal, février 2021.
Le cancer du sein de la patiente
est localisé. Le Dr Younan
retire la masse tumorale.
Mais il sait qu'au pourtour
de la plaie pourraient
se trouver des cellules
tumorales, des cellules sources
de récidives.
- Et il faut se rappeler,
de façon historique,
que les récidives arrivent dans
le même cadran, donc autour
de la tumeur à 80 %
et même plus.
- Normalement, à cette étape,
le Dr Younan doit refermer
la plaie. Des mois plus tard,
son collègue amorcera
la radiothérapie.
Mais aujourd'hui,
c'est différent.
Avec son équipe, le Dr Roberge
s'assure du bon déroulement
du traitement qui, faut-il
le rappeler, est une première
canadienne.
Son collègue tasse les tissus
en santé, ceux qui pourraient
se retrouver dans la mire
du faisceau.
- Donc, au lieu d'irradier
tout le sein et de causer
des effets de radiation à toute
la glande et au sein au complet,
on les limite sans toucher
la peau du tout, puisque
l'appareil est à l'intérieur
du sein et on les limite dans
le temps pour donner un seul
traitement, la journée
de la chirurgie et non pas deux,
trois, quatre, cinq semaines
après.
- Pour minimiser les effets liés
à l'irradiation, on dépose,
au fond de la plaie, une plaque
en acier inoxydable.
- On a un bouclier qui protège
derrière, au niveau du sein,
qui empêche toute radiation
au niveau du poumon et au niveau
du coeur. Donc, beaucoup moins
d'effets secondaires, absolument
aucun effet au niveau de la peau
du sein, qui est donc protégée
à 100 %.
Là, ça va être le jeu
de l'installer pour ne pas qu'il
bouge pas du tout, la précision
étant au millimètre pour pas
qu'il y ait de mouvement.
- On remodèle le tissu mammaire.
On le place pour que le pourtour
de la plaie se retrouve
à l'extrémité du collimateur.
- La position est parfaite.
Vous voyez, le AutoDock,
il est complètement dans le vert
partout. Vous voyez l'alignement
des deux, le collimateur
et le concentrateur d'électrons
et donc, la radiothérapie
va être donnée dans quelques
minutes.
On va sortir de la salle,
tout le monde.
- C'est un go.
On irradie la plaie.
Le faisceau, composé
d'électrons, tue les cellules
cancéreuses, celles invisibles
à l'oeil nu. Le tour est joué
en 60 secondes.
- Elle a peut-être été endormie
une demi-heure de plus.
Elle, elle s'en est pas rendu
compte. Son conjoint,
qui l'attendait dans la salle
d'attente, il a attendu
une demi-heure de plus.
Elle s'est réveillée,
puis son traitement est fini.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut faire
un traitement au lieu de 15?
Bien, il y a une question
de temps. La tumeur, on l'a pas
laissé progresser pendant
un autre deux mois, ça fait
qu'on a peut-être besoin
d'un peu moins de rayonnement.
Il y a une question physique
aussi. Il y a des organes
qui limitent combien on peut
donner de rayonnement par jour,
les poumons, le coeur, la peau.
Si on peut complètement exclure
ces tissus-là du faisceau,
on peut se permettre de donner
seulement qu'un traitement.
- Pour l'instant, on limite
la radiothérapie portative
aux patients qui ne requièrent
aucune chimiothérapie.
- Donc, tumeurs des patientes
ménopausées, des patientes avec
des tumeurs de moins que
2 cm, puis avec une biologie
pas agressive. Et donc,
avec un taux de récidive locale
un peu plus faible et pas
d'atteinte au niveau des
ganglions en dessous du bras.
- Dans le cancer du sein,
c'est là qu'on voit probablement
le plus grand pourcentage
des patientes qui pourraient
bénéficier de cette
technologie-là.
- Au-delà des avancées
que permet cet appareil,
la radiothérapie vit une période
excitante. De nouvelles études
laissent présager que nous
sommes à la veille
d'une révolution.
- On a compris récemment que si,
au lieu de le donner
sur des minutes, on le donne
sur une fraction de seconde,
que l'effet biologique
est différent, qu'on tue plus
de cancer pour moins
de dommages aux tissus sains.
Ça pourrait être une révolution
du traitement du cancer.
Si on s'imagine tous
les patients qu'on a,
qui viennent pour
30 traitements, ils viendraient
pour une demi-seconde,
puis le traitement serait fini.
Ça serait vraiment
spectaculaire. On est au tout
début de cette vague-là,
mais ça peut aller assez vite.